I'm sure you were starting to get like
my kids doing a long drive and they're
like Dad are we there yet
actually that's a pretty good example
for where a web hook works wonderfully
my kids continually ask me that question
over and over again are we there yet
they keep making that request the same
one over and over pulling me directly to
see if we've arrived at our destination
now typically my response is I'll tell
you when we get there more or less what
I'm promising is that when we get there
I will broadcast our arrival status
when that approach works like when my
kids actually decide to subscribe to my
status updates I can tell you that it
makes things a lot easier on the whole
car I don't get overloaded and they can
relax they just sit there and wait for
my update so much more efficient
so I guess what I'm attempting to
broadcast to you now is we're here we've
arrived at the start of the course